[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Hernández
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en la
revolución de la Inteligencia artificial
y nuevas herramientas que están
revolucionando todo como el chat gpt del
que todo el mundo habla para hablar de
ello no están en este estudio Mónica
fierro responsable pedagógica de lenguas
en el edc París business School
bienvenida Mónica
es coordinador de Inteligencia
artificial en la escuela de ingeniería
central superelec bienvenido Jules
Natalie Portilla doctorante en ciencias
de la educación de la Universidad de
París y de bienvenida natalyne
la revolución de la Inteligencia
artificial hoy nuestro asunto en Primera
Plana
gpt es la Inteligencia artificial de
texto de la que todo el mundo habla a
diferencia de otras Esta es capaz de
mantener una conversación de texto y
llegar a dar respuestas muy acertadas y
bastante naturales en cuestión de
segundos la capacidad de la herramienta
despierta no solo admiración también
temores muchos sienten que el programa
aparece demasiado convincente al limitar
el habla de un ser humano y prevén la
aparición de problemas son interrogantes
sobre la posibilidad de una fuerte
ruptura en áreas como la creatividad el
aprendizaje la educación el trabajo la
seguridad digital y la democracia en sí
misma hay motivos para preocuparse ante
lo que parece el Boom de la Inteligencia
artificial Cómo cambiarán nuestras vidas
repasemos algunas portadas de prensa
revista del spiggle califica de nuevo
poder mundial a la Inteligencia
artificial aquí en Francia el docinelli
veguegué se pregunta en su portada si
hay motivos para tener miedo de la
Inteligencia artificial internacional
habla en su portada de la locura
desatada por esta herramienta del chat
gpt Bueno Mónica para los poco iniciados
expliquemos un poco didácticamente a
grandes trazas Cuál es en qué consiste
esta herramienta
de manera general es un instrumento que
utiliza Inteligencia artificial y que
permite responder a preguntas de manera
muy rápida a cualquier tipo de preguntas
de hecho con una
extensión larguísima y lo más
impresionante es la manera en que lo
hace utilizando un lenguaje como si se
estuviera hablando con un ser humano
ahora eso obviamente crea ciertos
temores que podemos ver más adelante
sobre todo en el campo de Educación por
ejemplo Cómo podría esto eventualmente
reemplazar algunas profesiones etcétera
por precisamente la capacidad que tiene
de generar no solamente texto sino
también producciones artísticas etcétera
de manera muy rápida
Revolución temores locura mucha muchos
potenciales no sé cómo podemos calibrar
todos estos elementos a la hora de
hablar de este tema En mi opinión si es
una revolución
un nuevo tipo de chat ya existió a los
los en muchas empresas cuando vas en la
internet hay un chat Bots donde puedes
preguntar cosas pero muy rápidamente te
van a decir esperate vamos a poner en
contacto con alguien aquí va mucho más
lejos y
es muy poderoso que creo que no tomamos
en cuenta el poder de chat gpt por el
momento porque todavía estamos poniendo
poniendo plugin sobre eso para usarlo
para varios usos
y
obviamente que sí hay peligros pero como
en cualquier innovación y tenemos que
saber conocer estos riesgos para
superarlos
cuando se habla de revolución cognitiva
Cómo puede afectar ámbitos como la
educación que su ámbito Nataly
bueno a ver yo creo que para entender
como el impacto que puede tener hay que
entender que la educación es muy amplia
No no es lo mismo si hablamos en la
escuela primaria donde los niños están
aprendiendo a leer y escribir para los
más chiquitos
que si hablamos de escuela Media
Superior o superior
en donde el uso del chat gpt puede ser
diferente en todo caso lo que yo creo
que hay que entender es que el chat gpt
llegó y llegó para quedarse Aunque haya
personas que quieran
oponerse o o poner un límite a esto esto
ya llegó y si no entra si los si los
digamos grandes mandos de ciertas
escuelas como ya pudo suceder por
ejemplo aquí en Francia pop que dicen
que prohíben pues la entrada va a entrar
por abajo es decir por los estudiantes y
el impacto no es el mismo también según
el tipo de escuelas y puedo decirlo de
esta manera al que llega
Por decirlo un poco rápido creo que hay
estudiantes que van a estar mejor
preparados para usar esta herramienta
que es eso que es una herramienta en
donde ellos van a estar usándola y van a
tener van a poder usarla para
incrementar creatividad este poder hacer
cosas más interesantes y hay quienes
para quienes va a ser al contrario una
herramienta que puede que limite ciertos
aspectos de creativos y cognitivos
porque esa Revolución en el ámbito
educativo Sí claro que sí y estoy de
acuerdo con Natalie es creo que debemos
partir del presupuesto que la tecnología
llegó y hay que adaptarse a ella para
Pues precisamente explotar aprovechar
todas las ventajas que seguramente si
nos trae y creo que y es para mí en este
momento el principal aporte desde ya de
chat es nos está obligando a los actores
en educación a hacernos una pregunta que
habíamos dejado un poquito en segundo
plano y es Okay Cuál es el propósito
real de la educación qué competencia
necesitan desarrollar nuestros
estudiantes hoy las clases yo me imagino
que Ustedes deben estar de acuerdo son
clases un poco fijas que no están en
línea con la realidad extracurricular de
nuestros estudiantes los estudiantes que
están que nacieron que crecieron con
tecnología todo está a distancia de un
clic que están siempre conectados
entonces son estudiantes que aprenden de
manera distinta y la y la y los los
formatos de clase digamos hoy en día no
están digamos aprovechando esas
competencias que ellos están
desarrollando por fuera de clase
Entonces yo creo que nos está nos está
diciendo ok Les estoy dando una
posibilidad de Acceder al conocimiento
de manera muy rápida una base una base
que antes les tomaba ustedes de pronto
mucho tiempo construir ahora vamos a
pensar en el desarrollo de otras
actividades como como las habilidades
blandas creo que se dice en español La
la el pensamiento crítico el aprendizaje
por los pares reconocer una propaganda
por ejemplo Y eso va a hacer que las
tareas pues en educación modifiquen y se
vuelvan también más
por lo que tengo entendido está
disponible esta herramienta en 100
idiomas Jules en todos ellos sabemos que
en el caso del español si pudiéramos
comparar con el inglés
el inglés va a ser la persona más
poderosa porque porque está más
entrenada con la cual porque
para ser tan inteligente
con ese todo todo el internet todo
internet hasta 2021 y algo así y más
información tiene lo más poderoso va a
hacer así que como el internet está
tiene muchas muchas páginas en inglés sí
tiene una lógica hegemónica el inglés en
este tema perro el español el francés
Igual yo más más raras
están bien muy poderosas su potencial de
generar contenidos es inmenso no solo
responde a datos fríos también puede por
ejemplo escribir una carta de
reconciliación con un amigo con una ex
pareja es decir y aquí viene una gran
Revolución entiende de sentimientos eso
es algo nuevo completamente no O porque
para escribir a una carta una ex pareja
explíquenmelo si no natalio Mónica No
creo que entienda de sentimientos él
imita miramos en función de todo el
input que tiene
Pero sigue faltando yo para ponerles un
ejemplo en una de mis clases le dije a
mis estudiantes Ok van a discutir con
hpt en inglés como si fuera un personaje
de que ustedes les gusta Obama y los
mosca etcétera el que quieran Shakira
y todos la respuesta de todos el
feedback fue el mismo es decir es
impresionante la información que nos da
y tiene algo del estilo en el que
hablarle el personaje pero falta falta
emoción falta un poco entender también
el contexto de la pregunta entonces creo
que hay mucha es un excelente trabajo de
descripción y de imitación pero no hay
aún En todo caso una una un análisis
lógico profundo y un entendimiento del
contexto como para que
estamos en una etapa embrionaria que
vamos a evolucionar hacia lo que está
comentando efectivamente Mónica no sé
Natalie a ver de lo que tengo entendido
emociones no computa O sea sí si es una
computadora inmensa
no sé si es computadora pero esta
Inteligencia artificial Es inteligente
pero no es humana y emociones no tiene
y no entiende tampoco lo que dice o sea
si si se enoja no va a sentir dolor no
se puede enojar no puede sentir enojo no
puede sentir dolor no puedes sentir
alegría entonces lo que hace es que va a
tomar todo lo que tiene como información
sobre Reconciliación sobre Qué es un
poema amoroso sobre lo que es este no sé
cómo ese tipo de datos y lo que entendí
que hace Es que hace como algo como una
media de toda esta información y
entonces lo que regresa o sea lo que le
va a dar a luz al que usa este chat gpt
es algo muy promedio es algo muy banal
no no van a llegar no va a ser frases
que te llegan al corazón O sea no tienes
aparte de la creación humana en donde en
donde en donde se sobrepasa el límite de
las palabras en donde nos llega eso no a
pesar de ya utilizar una modalidad que
logra entender el contexto del uso de
palabras permitiendo concatenar mejor
los textos los programas anteriores
digamos que no respondían también al
usuario O aún sonaban demasiado
artificiales para hallar esa media de la
que hablaba Natalie entiendo Yule Y esta
es la innovación que permite el chat gpt
pero seguimos siendo hablando de
Inteligencia artificial y inteligente sí
es algo muy inteligente muy poderoso no
podemos decir que no Pero sigue siendo
artificial está hecho por gente
es código es código no es nada emocional
y las emociones que ponen son emociones
que han visto en la vida real en
internet en literatura Por cierto que en
los próximos meses esperan una aluvión
esto los municipios esperan una aluvión
de herramientas muchos programadores ya
son copiloto un asistente virtual que
escribe código y una popular aplicación
de notas notion que ha incorporado otro
para resumir textos Traducir y proponer
ideas no sé si podemos decir que estamos
ante un Boom
es el super asistente que nunca hemos
tenido Sí eso es cierto el objetivo
final es tener esa especie de súper
asistente En mi opinión Sí y lo temo
creo que lo tenemos que tomar Así un
profesor tienes un nuevo super asistente
perorista tienes un nuevo guisante pero
no va a ser tu trabajo te va a ayudar a
hacer lo mejor
estoy de acuerdo que es el asistente de
quien lo sabe usar y creo que ahí hay
una una cuestión también que tiene que
ver con la educación que a ver es que no
es Porque existe que va a haber hablabas
de democracia en un inicio cuando abrías
se parece pareciera que fuera
democrático porque cualquiera que tiene
una computadora y acceso a internet
tiene acceso a chat gpt por el momento
por el momento dicen que eventualmente
lo van a echar gp4 creo que va a ser de
pago de pago pero por el momento es
democrático porque parece democrático
porque cualquiera puede tener acceso
pero una cosa es tener acceso y otra
cosa es saber usarla saber hacer las
preguntas correctas Ese es por ejemplo
una cuestión de Educación nos formamos
desde la más tierna infancia hasta los
universitarios Cuando hacemos un
doctorado a saber
hacer las preguntas correctas Cómo hacer
una pregunta cuál es una buena pregunta
eso no cualquiera lo puede hacer
entonces aquel que ya tiene una
estructura cognitiva humana este para
para poder hacer las preguntas correctas
va a poder tener como como asistente el
chat gpt y creo que son quienes de por
sí ya son los este los que están mejor
digamos puestos que van a poder usar de
mejor manera vamos a indagar en esa
brecha social que acaba de abrir Natalie
Pero va a ser a vuelta de pausa quien en
Primera Plana hasta ahora
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y 24 punto com
la historia de nuestro mundo está en
constante cambio el flujo de información
es cada vez mayor estamos ahí con todos
los temas nos comprometemos con la
verificación desde el terreno en todas
las circunstancias para anticipar el
futuro y entender el presente lo
acompañamos 24 horas 7 días a la semana
trans 24 una mirada diferente a la
actualidad libertad
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando de Inteligencia artificial y de
la herramienta del chat gpt un Boom de
la Inteligencia artificial que se lanza
Casi casi podríamos decir a reorganizar
el mundo hay una carrera tecnológica y
una empresarial vamos a hablar también
si hay un tiempo jurídico que se tiene
que acoplar a todas estas herramientas
no sé si podemos hablar de incluso
modificar equilibrios geopolíticos a
nivel mundial a través de estas
herramientas ahora mismo no porque los
mejores siguen los americanos y
es americano despensador por americanos
pero
podría cambiar cosas porque hay cosas
como censura cosas así que van a ser muy
difícil de
bypass
y esquivar Sí y vamos a ver cómo la
legislación
va a tener en cuenta a tomar en cuenta
Eso Eso no es nuevo la Inteligencia
artificial hay mucha gente que trabaja
sobre más sobre cómo hacer algo que sea
ético y tenemos que incluir tarjeta y
luego están haciendo en eso Claro porque
luego está la carrera jurídica la Unión
Europea ya desarrolló una legislación en
la materia que pretende definir
aplicaciones que crean un riesgo
inaceptable como un sistema
gubernamental por ejemplo
parecido a lo que impulsa china pero
claro la duda aquí si conseguirán los
tiempos judiciales acoplarse al ritmo
tecnológico
siempre El Judicial va a ser de retraso
con el Tecnológico hay países que son
que hacen mucha prudencia como Francia
por ejemplo y es difícil pero intentan
de poner
hay países donde
el Tecnológico va a estar mucho mucho
más rápido volvamos al ámbito de la
educación con Mónica y con Natalie
porque claro todas estas herramientas No
sí son Hasta qué punto son una amenaza
para el aprendizaje y la creatividad es
decir la tentación de estudiantes por
ejemplo de usar el programa
para encontrar respuestas rápidas Y
listas para sus tareas Nataly Cómo se
vigila eso a partir de ahora cuéntanos a
ver la trampa siempre ha existido antes
de echar que ya existía y va a seguir
existiendo no estamos dando ideas a
nadie
y de que los estudiantes lo van a usar
lo van a usar creo que
lo que hay que hacer es que los como
decía Mónica hace rato los maestros
profesores tienen que también integrar
el chat gpt dentro de su clase inclusive
no para poder qué sé yo por ejemplo algo
que Chad se hace muy bien Es que tiene
la estructura muy clara cuando tú le
haces una pregunta siempre va a
contestar de la misma manera tiene una
introducción va a tener un argumento con
ejemplos y siempre va a tener una
conclusión Y eso Por ejemplo es algo que
intentamos enseñar a nivel universitario
por ejemplo entonces puede ser una un
ejercicio de que la tarea la haga chat
gpt Yo no te estoy pidiendo que escribas
el ensayo pero sí que analices Cuál es
la estructura Y por qué esa estructura
funciona puede ser un ejemplo no pero lo
que definitivamente sí hay que hacer es
que es que hay que pensar qué es lo que
estamos evaluando si estamos evaluando
el conocimiento como tal al que de todas
maneras tenemos acceso de por sí con
Google con de muchas otras maneras
sino cómo lo uso el soft Gil Cómo cómo
cómo voy a yo aprender con h este
conocimiento que que ya viene organizado
por chat gpt sobre todo que también hay
veces como decías tú que hay respuestas
falsas O sea a ti te puso África en tu
programa cuando no lo hay Cuando hice
una búsqueda pero yo escuché de
de un poeta escuché un podcast en donde
le hace preguntas sobre poesía y no
Claro que no no O sea ya muy avanzado el
nivel ya no sabe contestar entonces
también puede ser como busquen una
respuesta te conteste Y tú como
estudiante me vas a decir si es verdad o
no es verdad lo que te está diciendo
chat gpt entonces hay maneras en donde
se le da la vuelta creo yo Mónica
penaliza la creatividad
de acuerdo pero creo que hay dos maneras
de verlo no una es la la postura un poco
más tradicional un poco más reticente al
cambio y es que algunas universidades lo
han hecho de hecho prohibimos y la
utilización de la escritura de ensayos
etcétera y la otra un poco más un poco
más mente abierta y eso OK Vamos a ver
cómo adaptamos esto a nuestro programa a
nuestros a la educación lo que ha
mostrado la Inteligencia artificial
hasta hoy en día es principalmente un
aporte positivo es decir quitar cargas
pesadas para profesionales que están
sobrecargados en el caso específico de
la educación por ejemplo ayudar en los
en los
en los caminos individuales de cada
estudiante para que puedan desarrollarse
de sus dificultades que puedan aprender
a su propio ritmo etcétera entonces ha
sido muy benéfico
es para mirar más precisamente la
utilización de ppt en para evitar plagio
Y eso Por ejemplo creo que hay que verlo
de la otra manera como decíamos hace un
momento es cómo modificamos esas tareas
hay un hay un profesor es bastante
interesante de la University en
Pensilvania que inscribió ya desde ya en
su silabus de curso chayote y le exige
casi a sus estudiantes a utilizarlo y le
dice ok ahora el instrumento antes
estaba pues no estaba en sus manos ahora
ustedes lo tienen
pregúntenle al al instrumento va a
producir algo y ustedes van a tener el
rol un poco del profesor del evaluador y
van a comenzar a criticar las respuestas
que la que la que va a generar entonces
una manera distinta de verlo ya nos
estamos evaluando No simplemente Ok la
capacidad de escribir un cierto peso de
manera medianamente coherente sino cómo
lo vamos a analizar críticamente y esas
competencias son las que estamos yo creo
en las que debemos enfocarnos hoy en día
actualizar va a haber menos problema
creo yo En plagio porque obviamente sí
un estudiante que que utiliza para
para su tarea o lo que sea debe citar
utilice hpt en tableta al pedazo pero lo
importante va a ser Cuál es la reacción
a lo que produjo el instrumento claro
razonamiento iba a buscar cosas que
salen en internet internet donde dice De
verdad Así que lo importante no es la
solución final es entender Cómo llegamos
a esta solución y por eso hay que poner
las buenas preguntas Exacto Entonces Esa
es la conclusión que el que maneje bien
la esta herramienta es el que sepa hacer
las buenas preguntas
Esa es la clave no de esta herramienta
en nuestra vida cotidiana los algoritmos
no son desde luego algo nuevo los usa
por ejemplo Netflix para recomendarnos
series o publicidad en redes les
pregunto la Inteligencia artificial va
un paso más allá con esos razonamientos
palpables es decir esos algoritmos se
perfeccionan respecto al usuario
respecto a nuestra vida cotidiana
es algo nuevo es algo Bastante antiguo
Pero hay un Boom Desde hace dos años
tres años cuatro años pero es
exponencial y y va a ser cada día más
adaptado al usuario a tu a tu Y eso es
eso increíble es que va a ser como he
dicho antes tu asistente personal y no
eres asistente de Netflix o de algo así
después hay modelos económicos hay que
entenderlo y
si es tu asistente gratis es que alguien
gana de eso porque claro un modelo
económico detrás Y si Google modifica
nuestra forma de ver el mundo por su
hegemonía como buscador chat gpt también
podemos modelar una forma de ver el
mundo o no no lo creen así Mónica
la forma de ver el mundo somos nosotros
los que vamos somos nosotros que vamos a
ver Sí pero lo vemos por ejemplo Cuando
hacemos una búsqueda en Google me
refiero salen unos contenidos primero
entonces esos contenidos tienen una
jerarquía Y esa jerarquía modifica un
poco nuestra forma de ver el mundo
lógicamente no Sí es verdad es verdad
Pero bueno una vez más nosotros tenemos
también la
cuando nosotros hacemos una búsqueda por
ejemplo tenemos palabras claves
específicas que utilizamos y la la el
instrumento un motor de investigación
por ejemplo nos va a proponer las cosas
que más van a encajar con lo que
nosotros estamos buscando entonces
efectivamente si hay puede haber un
acierto un cerdo privilegio de algunas
por ejemplo en el caso de los de las
advertidamente
pagas que que aparecen primero en Google
pero realmente el quien está dando la
orden de lo que quiere específicamente
somos nosotros
sí yo no estoy Completamente de acuerdo
en el sentido en el que por ejemplo
Google sí se acuerda de qué es lo que tú
quieres ver de qué es lo que sí te gusta
y te va dando cada vez más respuestas de
lo que orientadas orientadas Y entonces
al final terminas viendo solo lo que
quieres ver pero tú lo pediste Sí sí tú
lo pediste pero entonces si estás Este
te está encerrando de alguna manera y
además ya regresando al chat gpt en ese
sentido Por ejemplo este es una
herramienta que al final Al fin y al
cabo detrás hay seres humanos y ha sido
entrenado y él lo dice yo he sido
entrenado soy un lenguaje entrenado y
quién lo entrena lo entrena en ciertas
personas y entonces en un inicio tenemos
tanto los inputs no O sea Cuál es la
información que hay detrás pues
información que ha sido escrita por
siempre personas similares y Estados
Unidos mucho más mucho más en inglés
podríamos decir que es una herramienta
que ha sido creada por hombres que falta
una visión por ejemplo femenina A ver es
que yo no conozco al equipo Entonces no
podría firmarlo pero por dónde viene y
el hecho de que casi siempre los
ingenieros son hombres y que casi
siempre son blancos bueno en Francia
casi siempre provienen de de estratos
sociales favorecidos
quisiera yo intuir este se me fue la
palabra pero decir que sí que que sí hay
más hombres y entonces quienes
entrenaron a Chad gpt son ellos y
entonces las respuestas que vamos a
tener en un inicio son esas y luego
conforme yo lo voy a entrenando al mío
al mío propio diciéndole Esto sí esto no
que yo le estoy terminando de entrenar
cierto se vuelve mi mi el mío pero
también estoy dando información de
también está muy bien que veamos la
herramienta sin temores sin alarmas pero
con espíritu crítico también me parece
muy bien no que lo analicemos con los
con ese espíritu y
efectivamente lo que dice sobre el
hombre que va a hacer la tecnología los
ingenieros son hombres en Francia
en mayoría hay países donde no es el
caso y es algo porque
trabajamos mucho es se puede corregir
eso hay cosas que se llama el bias y
intentamos de hacer para que la
Inteligencia artificial
sea más abierta y no y por ejemplo el
reclutamiento
se usa mucho la Inteligencia artificial
y han visto al principio que tomaban
Broncos hombres porque históricamente
para los puestos buscados eran hombres
blancos y eso lo están cambiando porque
no es normal muy interesante esta vía
quiero preguntarles para acabar si
gracias al desarrollo de la Inteligencia
artificial creen que descubriremos cosas
de nuestro mundo que aún no sabemos
en los próximos iba a decir años quizá
meses
Mónica
porque estamos como digo estamos
llegando más rápido a cosas que nos
tomaban mucho tiempo hacer nos dan una
base para que nuestra creatividad
despegue para para mejorar a partir de
una base que por cierto es muy buena
entonces yo creo que sí que nos va a dar
el instrumento nos va a ayudar nos va a
dar sobre todo más tiempo para hacer más
creativos para analizar para para ver
las cosas diferentes yo creo que sí pues
lo que yo ya no tengo más en esta
edición en Primera Plana ha sido un
placer compartir con ustedes
Mónica Natalie este tiempo para
investigar esta herramienta está este
Boom de la Inteligencia artificial ya lo
ven los riesgos los potenciales y Pero
bueno con el espíritu crítico que
siempre intentamos tener en este
programa muchísimas gracias y a todos
ustedes nos vemos la próxima semana
quien en Primera Plana gracias
[Música]